The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high-quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or view
additional materials from
hundreds of courses, visit MIT
OpenCourseWare at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: As you can probably
tell from the volume of my
voice, I'm not Moungi.
I'm Bob Field, and I will be
lecturing today as a special
booby prize, because Bawendi
is so wonderful.
Last time you heard about
work and heat.
So there's p v work and it's
given by the integral minus p
external dv or just
the integral from
one to two of dw.
And this little slash here
means an in inexact
differential.
The reason for inexact doesn't
mean it's a crummy
measurement, it means that it's
path dependent, and so
the value of this integral
depends on how you get from
one to two. w greater than zero
means that work is done
on the system, and it's really
important to keep track of the
signs of these things.
For heat, heat is defined, or
the energy unit for heat,
calorie, is defined as the
amount of heat needed to raise
one gram of water from 14.5
degrees c to 15.5 degrees c.
That great deal of specificity
implies that heat is also
path-dependent and again we have
the convention that if
heat is added to the system,
the quantity is
greater than zero.
OK, so that's a quick
statement of what
happened last time.
Today we're going to talk
about heat capacity.
The first law, a process that
takes a gas from p1, V1, T to
p2, V2, T examined for
various paths.
And what you'll find is that the
maximum work out is obtain
for a reversible path.
We'll then look at the quantity,
internal energy,
which we define through the
first law, and we think of it
as a function of two variables
T and V. And whenever we say
something like that, we'll be
able to write a differential,
the partial of u, with respect
to T at constant V, dT, plus
the partial of u with respect
to V at constant T dV.
So, if we write something
like this, it implies
this kind of equation.
And the main points of the
latter part of the lecture is
what are these quantities?
How do we measure them?
How do we understand them?
This one turns out to be the
heat capacity, and this one
turns out to be something
that we measure in
the Joule-free expansion.
So, that's the menu for today,
at least that's what Moungi
assigned me to cover, and
I'll do the best I can.
So, let's talk about
heat capacity.
Heat capacity relates the amount
of heat that you add to
the system to the change in
temperature, and this is the
relationship.
The heat-added, temperature,
and this is a
proportionality constant.
Heat capacity depends on path.
So, here are two kinds
of experiments.
Here we have a fixed volume, and
we have a little candle,
and we're adding heat, and
when we add heat, the
pressure does what?
STUDENT:
PROFESSOR: It increases
and the temperature.
OK, we're you know,
this is MIT.
You guys know something.
You should yell it out,
not just whisper it.
You have the confidence --
I mean maybe up the street we
whisper, but here we know it.
And, so here is a different kind
of system where we have a
constant external pressure.
We add heat to the system.
And so here the volume
can change.
The temperature can change.
And so as we add heat here, the
temperature goes up and
the volume -- that was even
quieter than last time.
OK, but you know it.
You understand it.
Now, the coefficient that
relates the amount of heat in
to the temperature change
is obviously going to be
different for these two cases.
in this case, where we have a
fixed volume, we say dq is
equal that Cv, heat capacity
dT, where the v specifies
what's constant for the path.
And so this is one path,
constant volume.
This has a particular value.
Over here, we have dq=Cp dT, the
heat, the proportionality
between heat and temperature
rise is given by this, the
constant pressure
heat capacity.
They're different quantities.
If we want to know the total
heat added to the system, we
can measure it, which is the
straightforward thing, but
sometimes you want to calculate
in advance, or
it on an exam.
So, we do an integral over a
path, for the heat capacity
along that path, dT.
So, for Cp and Cv, these are
often quantities that are
measured as a function of
temperature, and one could, in
fact, calculate this integral.
For most problems on exams,
those quantities are constant,
independent of temperature.
But there's no guarantee
that they will be.
Now I get to tell a fun story.
The relationship between heat
and work was initially
proposed in the 1940's
by Joule.
Now, there are two stories about
Joule and how he came to
this insight.
One is that he observed when
people were machining cannon
barrels, a lot of heat was
generated, and there was a lot
of work done.
And so maybe the work
generated the heat.
Or there was a relationship
between work and heat.
Well, this is ridiculous because
people were making
cannons long before 1840.
The other story, which is
probably just as untrue, is
that Joule, on his honeymoon,
took his wife to a mountain
resort, and they were sitting at
the bottom of a waterfall,
and he had this wonderful
idea.
And that was the water at the
bottom of the waterfall is
probably going to be hotter than
the water at the top of
the waterfall.
So he grabbed his thermometer,
and went and made a couple of
measurements and discovered
the first law of
thermodynamics.
In fact, the water at the bottom
of the waterfall is
hotter than the water at the
top of the waterfall.
And the idea was that gravity
did work on the water and
falling, and that work led to
the generation of heat.
If you think about this, you
probably can come up with
several other ideas for how the
water at the bottom might
be warmer than at the top.
I mean it's flowing fast at
the top, and it's sort of
pooled at the bottom, and there
is sunlight and all
sorts of things that could
make this coincidental as
opposed to an insightful
observation.
But it's a good story,
Joule decided that there must
be a direct relationship
between work and heat.
They are the same quantity.
They are both forms of energy.
And so, we have this cartoon.
Again, we have an open beaker
and a candle, and we're
putting only heat into this
beaker, and the temperature
goes from T1 to T2.
And delta T is given by the
heat, which has to do with how
much of the candle burnt,
divided by the constant
pressure heat capacity.
Now you could do a similar sort
of thing, but instead of
having a candle, you have a
paddle wheel, and the paddle
wheel is spun by a weight
that's dropping
from here to here.
So, this weight is being
spun-- now I'm really
fantastic at drawing this
mechanical device, but you can
imagine that dropping
a weight can cause a
paddle wheel to turn.
And we know about gravity,
and we know about work.
So, if you're doing physics,
work is the integral of force,
dx, x1 to x2.
Right, that's work.
Now, gravity, well force,
is equal to mass times
acceleration, and the
acceleration due
to gravity is g.
The force, as this weight drops
is constant, and so the
work is just going to be
m g h, where this is h.
So, it's a trivial matter, by
looking at what is the weight,
and how far does it drop, to say
OK, how much work is done
by the paddle wheel.
And this is in an isolated,
in an adiabatic container.
All the energy that is inserted
into this, which
might be turbulence initially,
becomes heat, or becomes -- it
raises the temperature.
And so, again, we see a
temperature increase, and we
know the work, and the
temperature increase, it's a
constant pressure thing.
And so we now have
two observations.
The same temperature increase,
work and heat, and we have a
relationship between
heat and work.
The first law of thermodynamics
is --
I'm fine.
I don't --
I'm all set, I only
use this chalk.
I brought it with me.
The first law of thermodynamics,
written
concisely is dw plus dq, two
inexact differentials,
integrated over any closed
path, is zero.
This is an abstract and
powerful mathematical
statement of the first law
of thermodynamics.
There are much better or more
appealing expressions.
One is, du, u is called the
internal energy or just the
energy, is equal
to dq plus dw.
OK, notice we have two inexact
differentials and exact
differentials.
This is a condition.
If you have a quantity which
is constant over any closed
path, that quantity is a
thermodynamics state function.
So, this observation is
equivalent to saying that
there must be something that
is path independent.
Therefore, we don't have
a cross through the d.
And the first law says, well
heat and work are different
forms of energy, and we can
add them, and the path
dependence of these two things
is somehow cancelled in the
fact that we have this
internal energy.
So, we can also write delta u as
integral from 1 to 2 of du.
That's u2 minus u1,
and it's q plus w.
So, these two quantities, again,
are path dependent.
This is not.
That's the first law
of thermodynamics.
It seems trivial, but it's
really important.
It's almost as important
as the second law of
thermodynamics, which you'll
see in a week or so.
There is a corollary to this.
If we say we have a system, and
it's in its surroundings.
We can talk about du for the
system well, that's q plus w.
And we can say du for
the surroundings.
Well the system got its work
from the surroundings.
It either had work, got its heat
from the surroundings, or
it got worked on by
the surroundings.
And so, we can immediately write
this and then we can
write du for the universe,
which is system plus
surroundings is equal to zero.
This is the corollary.
It's due to Clausius and it
says the energy in the
universe is conserved.
Fairly powerful statement, and
that's another form of the
first law of thermodynamics.
OK, enough for really
great discoveries.
Now let's talk about some
simple observations on
isothermal gas expansions.
The purpose here is to look at a
series of processes in which
temperature is held constant,
and we're going to calculate
how much work we get from
allowing a gas to expand under
various conditions.
And what we'll discover is that
when we allow the gas to
expand reversibly, we
get the most work.
This is neat.
This is important.
OK, so we have constant
temperature, because it's
isothermal.
And let's do a series
of experiments.
First let's set the external
pressure equal to zero.
So we have an experiment
that looks like this.
We have a piston.
We have a pair of stops.
We have another pair of stops.
We start at p1, V1. and p
external is equal to zero.
In other words, this
is vacuum.
And so what happens when we
remove these stops is that the
piston slams up against the
next pair of stops.
It goes very fast.
You could calculate the time.
You could do all sorts of stuff,
but what is important
is that this piston in moving
from here to here did no work
on the surroundings because
work is the integral of
pressure dv, and the pressure
external is zero.
It doesn't matter what the
pressure internal is.
This is a point that is often
confusing, because you can
think, well maybe I could
calculate what the internal
pressure is even for this
very rapid process.
It doesn't matter.
Thermodynamics is asking you,
what work does this thing do
on the surroundings or the
surroundings do on the system?
And there is no work done on
the surroundings because
pressure is zero.
So, the work for this process is
the integral, or minus the
integral, V1, V2, p dV.
And it's p external and
p external is zero,
so there's no work.
OK, the next example is, well,
when this piston slams up
against these stops, the gas
has expanded -- we're doing
this isothermally, so this is in
contact with the heat bath.
The gas has expanded.
It has a particular pressure
and a particular volume.
Every time you do the experiment
in equilibrium with
the heat bath at T, you'll
get the same p2 and V2.
One can know them.
And so we can then say, OK,
let's do this second
expansion. and let's set
p external equal to p2.
And we do the same
sort of thing.
We have stops here.
We have p1, V1.
And we don't really need
stops up here.
We have a weight on the piston,
and that weight is
chosen so that it
acts as though p
external is equal to p2.
We know the pressure is equal
to force per area.
And so we know the force for a
particular mass, and we know
the area of the piston. so we
know how to do this, and we
know this thing when it hit
these stops, the pressure with
p2, and the volume was V2.
Now we could put stops here at
V2, but this piston would just
kiss the stops.
It would stop there because
we've chosen p2.
The work for that process is
going to be minus V1, V2, p2,
because that's what we chose p
external to be, dV, and that's
going to be minus
p2, V2 minus V1.
That's the work.
V2 is larger than V1, and
so this quantity here is
positive, and we have a negative
sign because the
system did work.
OK, so now we can take the
result from this and put it
onto a p v diagram. p1, p2,
V1, V2 -- so here is the
initial situation, and here
is the final situation.
And the equation of state,
pressure versus volume at
constant temperature, is going
to have some form, let's just
draw it in there like that.
So that's an equation
of state.
It's like the ideal gas
law, and one could
know that in principle.
OK, so we did work -- oh, I
should mention p times V has
units of energy or
units of work.
Remember that, because you're
going to find lots of
thermodynamics quantities, and
you're often going to be
writing on exams, deriving
things on exams, and you're
going to almost always want the
combinations of quantities
to have units of energy.
So, dimensional analysis is
extremely valuable in
thermodynamics, and here
is an example of it.
Anyway, the work associated
with process number two is
described by this box.
Because we did work at constant
pressure, and so it's
just volume difference
times pressure.
OK, now we can do the process
in two steps.
So we start out with
our piston.
We have two weights on it.
So we have p1, V1.
We have stops.
We've chosen two weights,
so that this is p3.
External pressure is p3.
It's higher than p2.
So we remove the stops, and the
piston moves up, and now
we remove one of these weights.
and when we remove
one of the weights, this gives
an external pressure p2.
So, the piston moves up
again, one weight.
So here is p2, p external.
Here is p3.
And so we have the work
coming from two steps.
And it's trivial to calculate
what that will be, and when
you do that, if we put p3 in on
this diagram, what you end
up finding is that you get an
initial little bit of work
corresponding to V3.
So we break up our work into
three pieces, and we
get more work out.
So the final process involves
do it reversibly, or almost
reversibly.
We want p equal to p external
for the entire expansion, and
p external is decreased steadily
from p1 to p2.
How do we do this?
Well, we start out with our
usual system, and we have a
bunch of little pebbles on it.
Each weighing, say, one 100th
of the weight needed to
establish p external
is equal to p1.
We remove a pebble,
system expands.
We remove another one,
That's equivalent to doing the
integral, and so, what we end
up getting is that the
reversible work is equal to
minus integral V1, V2, p dV.
Because what we've done is we
forced p, pressure here, to be
equal to the external
pressure.
We've changed the external
pressure slowly, and again
this is isothermal.
There is a heat bath
here that keeps
the temperature constant.
So, the system does work on the
surroundings, hence the
minus sign.
Now, if this is an ideal gas, we
know that pressure is equal
to nRT over volume.
So we can put that in here
and do this integral.
We have minus V1, V2,
nRT over V dV.
These are all constant.
It's isothermal.
We can take them out.
It's a closed system, so the
number moles doesn't change.
The ideal gas constant doesn't
change, temperature doesn't
change, and so we just have
minus nRT integral V1, V2, dV
over V. Now, we are very gentle
in this course with
respect to knowing integrals,
but this is
one you have to know.
The integral of one over a
quantity is the natural log.
And so we can write this, minus
nRT log V2 over V1.
That should not take a breath.
You know that much
about integrals.
OK, now we actually would like
to simplify this or to write
this in terms of not the
volume change, but the
pressure change.
So, we have V2 over V1.
Well, what we can write that
using the ideal gas law twice,
V2 is equal -- pV = nRT.
So V2 = (nRT)/p2, and
V1 = (nRT)/p1.
So, the nRT's cancel, and
we have p1 over p2.
And so, we can rewrite this as
the work is equal to minus nRT
log p1 over p2, or nRT
log p2 over p1.
Now, p2 is less than p1, so this
is a negative quantity.
The system has done work.
So the reversible process, we
had this curve, and for the
irreversible processes, we got
this, and then this, whoops,
and now we get the
whole thing.
So for the reversible process,
the work done is the integral
under the pressure volume
state function,
the function of state.
OK, what time is it?
I'm going to actually get caught
up, make up for but
Bawendi's slow lecturing.
That doesn't mean it's better,
it just means that I'm making
up for a problem that
he created.
OK, so what do we know so far?
Maximum work out is by
reversible path.
Delta u is q plus w.
So the maximum work out required
the maximum heat in.
So a reversible process leads
to requiring certain
quantities to be maximized.
Now, we have u, q and w.
We have a relationship
between them.
Often, for a particular state
change, it is easy to
calculate two of these,
but not the third.
And because there is an explicit
relationship between
u, delta u, q and w, you can
always find the easy way to
derive the change in
internal energy or
the heat or the work.
Even if the thing that you
really want is an integral
that would be difficult
to evaluate.
OK, now, we're going to look
at the internal energy, and
we're going to pretend that it
is explicitly a function of
temperature and volume.
We could choose any two
quantities, and, in fact, it
turns out that these are going
to prove, after we have the
second law, not to be
the best choice.
But it's allowed to say the
internal energy is a function
of temperature and volume.
When you say that, it implies
that the differential is given
by this pair of partial
derivatives.
V dT, partial of u with respect
to the volume holding
temperature constant, dV.
So if you say this, it requires
you to say this.
Now, the purpose of this
exercise is to give you a
little bit of practice in
figuring out what these
quantities are.
And do a little practice
in manipulating these
differentials.
So, we have, we're interested
in the change in internal
energy for various experimental
constraints.
And so, one constraint is the
process be done reversibly.
Well then, du is equal to dq
reversible plus dw reversible,
which is minus p dV, because p
is equal to p external for a
reversible process, and
we can write that.
We could have isolated.
Suppose we're looking at the
system isolated from the
outside world.
Well, dq is equal to zero and
dw is equal to zero because
it's isolated.
So that implies du
is equal to zero.
We could do an adiabatic
process.
Adiabatic means there's no heat
transferred in or out of
the system.
We don't say anything about
whether the system does work
or has worked on -- implicitly
here, we're talking about a
closed system, so there's no
mass leaving the system.
But if it's adiabatic, then dq
is equal zero, and for an
adiabatic process, then
du is equal to dw.
OK, now this is a point
we want to be careful.
Be careful.
Suppose we are doing an
adiabatic process.
We can do it reversibly, or
we can do it irreversibly.
So suppose we do it
irreversibly.
Suppose we just remove stops,
and the system slams up
against the other stops.
Did no work.
Does that mean du is zero?
You bet it does not.
So, it's important to write this
little thing on here, du
is equal to the reversible
work, not just the work.
You can have a process where
you can measure an
irreversible process,
where you could
calculate the work done.
It could be zero.
It could be something else.
But if it's not reversible,
it's not du.
And you will be invited to
make that mistake on
an exam, I'm sure.
OK, so, the thing about a state
function is that the
function has a value for initial
conditions and at
final conditions.
And the difference
between those is
what you could measure.
If you measure something
else, you won't get du.
Be careful, and this is going
to be especially complicated
and confusing when we get to
quantities that have a more
obscure meaning like entropy.
I mean we can, we can sort of
understand why OK, the total
energy, if we measure it, we
measure a process which is not
reversible.
Well it might not give the
energy change for that
process, but when we have
a quantity which is more
obscure, which the definition
of that quantity requires a
very specific prescription for
calculating, you're going to
get into trouble.
So exam this and be sure
you understand that.
OK, constant volume.
Well for constant volume,
dw is equal to zero.
Why?
How does it do, what is work?
Well it's p v work if the
volume doesn't change.
There is no work.
So in this case du is equal to
dq, and we put a little v on
it to imply the work, the change
in internal energy is
equal to the heat added
at constant volume.
Nothing reversible about it.
It's now, all we have to do is
say we're going to have heat
at constant volume.
OK, and now we return to
this differential.
We want to ask the question,
what are these two quantities?
How do we know what they are?
This should be particularly
bothersome to you because, as
you've already experienced in
5.60, there are a lot of
partial derivatives. there
are a lot of variables.
There are a lot of things
held constant.
It's easy to get lost in this
sea of quantities, none of
which have obvious meaning.
So now what we're going to do is
start to extract what these
things mean.
OK, so for a constant volume
process, we can write du,
partial derivative of u with
respect to T at constant V,
dT, plus partial derivative
of u at constant V, dV.
OK, for constant volume,
this is zero.
So this term is gone, and we
rewrite this du, V is equal to
du/dT, at constant V, dT v.
So we, have a change in
temperature done at constant
volume, and we have a change
in internal energy done at
constant volume, and we
rearrange this.
And we discover that du/dT at
constant V is equal to du/dT
at constant V. What, have
I done something silly?
Oh well, yes I have. dq v, so
du v is equal to dq v and so
what I should have written here,
this is true, we can get
a partial derivative by taking
two total derivatives at the
same pressure, at the same
quantity, but what I really
wanted to do is to write dq
v is equal to the partial
derivative of T, constant v dT
v. OK, and now, we know the
relationship between heat and a
temperature change is given
by a quantity, a heat capacity
for a particular path, and
here it is.
So what we've discovered from
this relationship that du at
constant volume is equal to dq
v. We have discovered that
this partial derivative that
appears in the definition, the
abstract definition of the
differential for internal
energy, is just equal to the
constant volume heat capacity.
So, in this definition now, we
have one term which we know.
It's something that
we can measure.
We can measure the heat capacity
at constant volume,
and now we have another term,
and if we can figure out how
to measure it, we'll have
a complete form for this
differential which
will enable us to
calculate du for any process.
So let me write where I am
now, or we are now. du is
equal to Cv dT, plus partial of
u with respect to volume at
constant temperature dV.
So, we've simplified the
expression by replacing one of
the partial derivatives by a
quantity that we can measure.
And we like to know
what about this.
So we need an experiment
that will enable us to
measure this quantity.
And that's where we get Joule,
and I like to say it Joule's
free expansion -- it's usually
referred to as the Joule free
expansion, which sort of implies
that no energy flows,
which actually is true, but it's
an experiment proposed by
Joule, and the experiment
involves an adiabatic box.
So we have system insulated from
the outside world, and we
have two bulbs.
There's a valve between them.
And so we have gas and
we have vacuum.
So the Joule free expansion
involves opening this valve
and asking what happens when
this gas moves into the other
bulb or distributes between the
two. well since the gas is
expanding into vacuum
no work is done.
Since it's isolated,
no heat is added.
So du is equal to zero because
dq and dw are both zero.
So we can now take this
expression and rewrite it
under the condition of
du is equal to zero.
So we have du equal to zero,
just a zero here.
Cv dT constant u plus the
derivative du/dV at constant
T, dV at constant u.
This is just a number.
We don't have to specify that
it's measured at constant u.
It's just a number.
So now we rearrange this
expression, and so we get
du/dV at constant T is equal to
minus Cv times dT u over dV
u or minus Cv partial derivative
of temperature with
respect for volume a constant,
free energy, a constant
internal energy.
So, this is the quantity
we want.
It's related to the heat
capacity, the constant volume
of heat capacity and something
you could measure.
What happens as you expand
into volume?
Does the temperature go up?
Does it not change?
Joule actually did this
experiment, and he observed
that for the gas expansions
that he could do, that the
temperature did not increase
measurably.
So he made an incorrect
conclusion.
Because something was small
and unmeasurable, he said,
well the best of my knowledge
dT/dV at constant
u is equal to zero.
And that implies that since the
quantity we want is given
by this quantity, which is zero
times a constant, the
quantity we want is also zero.
So it would imply that du
was equal to only the
first term Cv dT.
Now, this is an important
lesson in
what you do in science.
You make an observation.
You make an observation doing
an experiment that is as
accurate as you can do.
And so an experiment said the
gas didn't increase its
temperature when it expanded
the vacuum.
And so the next thing you do is
you call up a journal and
say I've discovered a
fundamental law of nature.
And, so you propose that there
is no, that this derivative is
zero, and that the internal
energy is given
simply by this quantity.
It turns out that this quantity
here, which is called
eta of J the Joule free
expansion parameter, is not
quite zero.
When you expand a real
gas into vacuum, the
temperature goes down.
So this is a very small number
and for ideal gases, eta J is
equal to zero.
This quantity is exactly zero
for an ideal gas and we'll
discover why eventually it has
to do with what we mean by an
ideal gas it turns out.
And so for many, many problems,
especially on exams,
especially on this first exam,
you will be able to say that
this is the relationship between
internal energy and
temperature.
That u is a function of
temperature only.
It doesn't matter what
other things change.
The value of the internal energy
is only determined by
temperature.
But this is only true for
an ideal gas and it's
approximately true
for other things.
So, delta u is equal
to zero for all
isothermal ideal gas processes.
And it's approximately
equal to zero for
all real gas processes.
And so that means that delta
u is always calculable from
Cv(T) dT for any ideal
gas change.
So even if work is done,
it doesn't matter.
All you care about is what was
the temperature change?
And this is always the easy way
to calculate du, and it's
often the easy way to calculate
either q or w, using
the first law.
So, since du is equal to q plus
w, and for an isothermal
process this is equal
to zero, q = -w.
For an ideal gas, for an
isothermal process.
It simplifies your
life enormously.
You don't have to
calculate much.
OK, so it's time to stop, I did,
in fact, get caught up.
I hope you didn't mind the
enhanced velocity.
Now Bawendi can do the beautiful
stuff on lecture
number four.
Thank you.